[Musik]
hey was geht ab jetzt willkommen beim
neuen video hier wird wahrscheinlich
mein altes zimmer ich weiß nicht ob es
noch in erinnerung hatte
aber hier habe ich früher mal gewohnt es
ist irgendwie zu michler geworden hier
naja egal ich bin endlich mal wieder zu
hause ich glaub ich weiß ein monat gar
nicht hier sehr traurig irgendwie aber
ich habe mir gesagt du hast jetzt
wirklich schon eineinhalb monate oder so
kein mädchen jungs video oder jungs
mädchen thema mehr gemacht deswegen
abschluss gefragt hey was wollt ihr
sehen und keiner hat irgendwie eine idee
die ich gut fand ja deshalb muss ich
dann selber überlegen und ich bin auch
die grandiose idee kommt jetzt was wir
nicht nur ich gut finde
aber ich glaube hier auch zum teil und
zwar geht es um 10 dinge die mädchen
können und jungs nicht oder zehn dinge
die nur frauen können und männer nicht
und das ist der nachteil wenn man keine
softbox tag die sonne kommt gerade raus
und ich werde verdammt weh regal auf
jeden fall ist dass das thema ich will
gar nicht lange lagern auf wenn ich
schon wieder viel zu lang glaube ich
würde sagen wenn in zukunft wieder mehr
bock habt auch jungs mädchen videos oder
solche themen crêpes mit den kommentare
was ihr sehen wollt worüber sie reden
und lassen sich das und jetzt gespart so
ganz kurz doch die ersten fünf punkte
habe ich mir sehr überlegt die 2005 kam
von euch das netzwerk deswegen gibt es
einen kleinen unterschied zwischen wir
fangen an und zwar mit dem ersten punkt
ich muss sagen das heutige video basiert
sehr auf wissenschaftlichen studien und
zwar habe ich herausgefunden eine studie
aus keine ahnung wo besagt dass frauen
mit der zeit immer schöner werden männer
aber nicht wo ich mich ist ehrlich zu
frage die die studie entwickelt haben
ich glaube hier habe ich noch nie
gesehen auf jeden fall findet es einen
stuhl zuständig bevor jetzt an die
nächste generation und die noch nicht so
noch nächste generation nach und das
jetzt ja digitaler inhalte das heißt in
300 jahren könnte man das eigentlich
immer noch abrufen also an die jungs ich
hab euch jetzt schon gesagt wenn ihr zum
beispiel in 300 jahren lebt ihr habt
glück weil auch wenn ihr hässlichkeit
eure frau muss schon sein
baustellen und 300 jahren sind wirklich
alle frauen richtig attraktiv
es kommt natürlich
auch mal auf das auge des betrachters an
aber so wirklich jede frau wäre ich will
jetzt gar nicht mehr dazu sagen
jetzt wird wieder dunkel passt zum
nächsten punkt und war habe ich auch
herausgefunden 55,8 prozent aller
beziehungs-aus was jetzt die mehrzahl
von aus 1 aus gibt's nicht gibt er noch
einmal aus gibt mehrere beziehungs 50
prozent aller trennung gehen von frauen
aus dass frauen können sich eher trennen
als männer
warum auch immer oder es dann 62,8
prozent kann auch sein irgendwie fällt
mir grad auf alle punkte die ich
herausgefunden habe basieren auf
irgendwelchen studien normalerweise ist
irgendwie immer meine meinung aber heute
basiert alles auf studien als ob jetzt
könnt ihr auch eine menge lernen hier
auf alex ii ihr müsst mehr zur schule
gehen
schaut euch einfach meine video sagen
die basierende mich alle auf streng
wissenschaftlichen studien nicht bat der
nächste punkt doch der basiert auch auf
einer studie
und zwar wird gesagt dass frauen es
einfacher haben lernen auf high heels zu
laufen ich hab das jetzt zweimal
versucht und es ist einfach für mich
irgendwie so man denkst du forderst
wirst du niemals können vielleicht lernt
man als junger aufregend waren aber
dieses auf hohen schuhen laufen ist
vielleicht für das eine andere mädchen
oder die eine oder andere frau wirklich
deutlich leichter als für männer einfach
weil sie irgendwie vielleicht so sind es
jetzt total dumm begründen
ich lasse es einfach mal so ihr könnt ja
meine kommentare stein was ihr dazu
denkt stimmt das wirklich dass frauen es
leichter haben auf high heels laufen
also wenn jetzt mal eingehen wird und
sagen würde komm ich muss jetzt auch
einfach mal schön finden ist es dann
schwerer für sie das zu lernen
kein plan die studie sagt ja alex wie
sagt vielleicht aufgrund der
beinmuskulatur auf den letzten punkt von
mir bin ich ganz alleine gekommen
das wort gekommen kann man eigentlich
schon gut verwenden dafür und zwar hat
sie herausgefunden
oder ist schon wieder dass männer immer
nur einmal kommen können normalerweise
ich will jetzt auch mich nicht allzu
weit aus dem fenster lehnen als beim sex
sells es gibt bestimmt auch männer die
behaupten sie können dreimal
hintereinander kommen innerhalb von zehn
minuten ich weiß es nicht allerdings
können frauen aufgrund irgendwelcher
hormonausschüttung oder so
zehn mal kommen noch prämien
also das war jetzt erstmal so die
vorteile von mir die mir eingefallen
sind und jetzt hab ich euch aus
plötzlich gefragt hey was denkt ihr was
können nur frauen was können die mädchen
ihr habt mich komplett bombardiert das
wollen wir uns jetzt so die erste
nachricht mehr gut wer kreativ wäre ich
nie drauf gekommen und zwar frauen sind
die einzigen die tampons benutzen können
ja super ganz stark da muss man einfach
mal klatscht man erkennt ja auch unterm
kommt ist vielleicht nicht daran tun
aber es macht dann zwar nicht so sinn
aber ja du hast recht frauen sind die
einzigen die tampons sinnvoll benutzen
können
ob das jetzt im vorteil ist weiß ich
nicht aber ja ihr seid echt klasse das
ist ein punkt wo ich mir denke ja das
stimmt frauen sind die einzigen die
schwanger werden können
auch wieder weg und auch sachen ich
werde schon alleinig tropfen kommen weil
es einfach zu simplen so das war gar
nicht so meine denkweise dass sich mit
diesem video rüber bringen möchte ja
klar frauen sind die einzigen die
schwanger werden können bürger die
nächste sache macht echt sind und zwar
da bin ich nicht von alleine kommen
frauen oder mädchen wenn man halt
größere brüste aber wir gehen jetzt erst
mal davon aus jede frau hat natürlich
brüste man kann was mit seinem posten
festhalten ob es jetzt der später in der
schule das handy was auch immer man ganz
einfach hier rein tun und deshalb
festhalten
warum wird das jetzt wieder so heller
das gibt's doch nicht also darfst du auf
jeden fall recht ist eine coole sache
das würde ich auch gehen können ich habe
allerdings keine brüste glock so leicht
und kommen wir dass man zum letzten
punkt und zwar bin ich auch nicht
vorderreihe bekommen mädchen oder frauen
sind die einzigen
ich sage immer die einzigen es gibt
nicht viele angriffs gibt der männer
oder jungs oder männer und ich weiß gar
nicht wie ich das immer ich sagen frauen
als eigentlichen ich meine die meisten
von euch zu sind wahrscheinlich noch
mädchen deswegen nenne ich das einfach
mädchen auf jeden fall noch geschrieben
jungs können keine mädchen kleidung
anziehen mädchen aber schon und acht
natürlich erstmal recht ich muss
allerdings immer aufpassen was ich sage
damit nicht wieder in den kommentaren
steht das meinten zu sechs oder so ich
bin auf keinen fall ein mensch der so
denkt auch wenn es manchmal in
irgendwelchen videos der letzten jahre
von mir so rübergekommen
keine ahnung und zwar kann natürlich
auch jedermann frauen klamotten tragen
aber von der gesellschaft wird halt
eigentlich so angesehen es ist ganz süß
wenn mein mädchen jungs pullover anzieht
oder so boyfriend hosen und andersrum
wenn ein junger halten legen viele ihr
wisst was da raus kommen mir scheißegal
sei nicht halt jungs klamotten mache ich
am schönsten finde was ihr macht ist mir
egal wollte doch vielleicht mal
abdrücken weitere punkte in die
kommentare schreiben
wenn ihr auch bock gehabt dass ich mal
machen zehn dinge die nur mädchen
zehn dinge die die jungs genau also wenn
ihr da auch bock habt zehn dinge die nur
jungs können mädchen nicht danach nach
oben da schreibt in die kommentare
folgt auf instanz selbst da kommt viele
coole sachen freut mich mega dass die
letzte - so gekommen sind und wir sehen
uns morgen wieder morgen und der zweite
park von alter erraten ich erwarte eher
alter da könnt ihr mir auch wieder
vielleicht bilder schicken auf insider
so duda mit meinem bruder und wir sehen
uns rein